[Musique]
patricia seulement te ferait peur si tu
n'avais pas ton papa et à maman avec toi
oh bah oui parce que je me sentirais
abandonnée tout seul sans personne
et puis par mois par rapport aux non ça
fait ça ferait drôle du mois qu'est ce
que c'est exactement par rapport aux
autres par rapport au monde extérieur qu
un papa une maman qu'est ce qui
représente pour toi si on n'aurait pas
son papa et sa maman elle va pas on
pourrait passer brouillée parce que si
on n'aurait pas papa et maman on serait
presque rien que des petits amis autour
de toi ce qu'elles vivent tout comme toi
non bah y en ait qui mangent à la
cantine
je ne mange pas la cantine non tu
préfère rentrer de suite voir parce que
je trouve ce que fait ma manche est
meilleure qu'à la cantine ce que ces
moments qu'il l'ait fait que le cooking
se trouvait au sol en hauteur j'ai fait
95 nature
et toi corinne qu'est ce que tu as fait
moi j'ai fait de l'anglais toujours
aussi doué tu connais rien dis moi mon
anglais que tu ça je sais pas vous mais
elle est marrante et chaque fois qu'on
arrive en classe
whitmore lingam dit comme ça ouais à
good morning banger records les initie
sa mère lorsqu'il a remis ses good
afternoon good afternoon des coutures
son père véronique vrai coup dur j'ai
fini mon sac j'ai par contre avoir fait
manger parce que je connecte à 11h corp
et j'aimerais manger basse nous tous les
midis c'est nous deux mais là comme mon
frère là qui tabasse a aimé l'avoir moi
c'est vraiment aussi il y aurait pas
dans mon jeu c'est beaucoup moins je
vois si je mange de la viande peut-être
lâcher quoi que pas de sens personne on
les envoie sur les k23 pendant la
période des places comme en ce moment
vous n'êtes pas toujours tous réunis
c'est que des fois moi je suis en classe
parce qu'elle aussi puis après quand
vient 90 allait devoir faire je peux pas
rentrer tard des fois on ne voit pas
souvent ça tu manques de pas le voir
souvent ton papa ah bah oui parce que
quand on a fait quelque chose à l'école
on peut pas aller lui dr quand c'est pas
faire des mathématiques on peut pas les
deux modèles attaque nous aident donc
les papas c'est fait pour expliquer les
mathématiques et les mamans ça sert à
quoi les moments ça sert à apprendre de
plus de choses mon pauvre sur man et moi
dans votre beau carrosse je serai votre
fiancée je sais pas très bien ça va and
the girls of qu'au soir vers les plaines
mama alès pascal vient voir oui j'arrive
quelque chose à se faire signer
travailler et papa que ce qui contrôle
le vendredi avant deux bonnes heures
alain vendredi nous fait réciter une
leçon qui compte oui si pâques j'ai une
mauvaise note alors il nous dit la
prochaine fois il faudra faire mieux
et puis c'est la prochaine fois j'ai
noté david et les plus contents parce
que j'ai remonté mais ce qu'il se fâche
quelques fronts non ça dépend
quand par exemple j'ai plusieurs
mauvaises notes à la fois ça lui plaît
pas avec 10 h
savage
[Musique]
je crois que ton papa était un petit
garçon abandonné
oui il vous l'a dit oui est ce que tu
penses que c'est normal qu'une femme
puisse abandonner son enfant et l'or
parce que je me suis mis dans la tête
que si on veut avoir un enfant c'est pas
pour l'abandonner après c'est une chose
que je ne crois pas ah non ça jamais
monsieur parent est ce que ça compte
beaucoup dans l'éducation que vous leur
donnez la tendresse on l'entouré
absolument je leur donne ce que je n'ai
pas plus à voir est ce que j'aurai
désirez avoir alors je fais en sorte de
leur donner vous pensez que c'est
essentiel pour un enfant c'est
primordial c'est là vous allez voir le
coucher de soleil
[Musique]
pour rappel qu'est ce que tu penses
qu'ils font quand ils sont tous seuls
les enfants
enfin seul champ nuit tu comptes octave
à mon travail pas qu'elle soit tout le
temps la maison ici oui tu trouves ça
normal
hop un peu est-ce que tu serais capable
de faire ça quand tu seras plus grande
oui capable oui mais je sais pas encore
si je le ferai parce que si j'aime mon
métier j'aurai envie d encore de
travailler tu te rends compte que ta
maman passe toujours en dernier pour
tous même si ça c'est parce que si elle
voulait elle pourrait travailler mais
elle préfère sacrifier tout pour pour
rester là voilà parents quand on est une
maman de deux enfants
on n'a pas beaucoup de temps à passer
dans sa salle de bain non pas du tout
c'est vous qui êtes responsable du
rythme de la maison oui une bonne mère
qui veut être bien s'occuper des enfants
je crois qu'il faut ré derrière partout
enfin que le moment un travail c'est pas
pareil enfin pour moi il faut quand même
une surveillent ce que pour donner de
l'argent de poche
donnons leur donne pas de là enfin je
leur donne de l'argent de poche cause
est une récompense enfin présent des
bonnes notes à l'école des enfants
binger pascal qu'il est mis dans sa
tirelire et les patriciens aussi mon
mari me pailler à la banque ne peut pas
y aller quoi gens demandent s'ils
peuvent prêter de l'argent pour finir là
la journée la semaine s'était pas alors
ils prêtent tous les deux alors
j'accepte tous les duos comme ça y'a pas
de problème
et puis y'a pas de jaloux tes parents te
met en garde contre ce qui peut arriver
dans la vie oui il ya longtemps qu'ils
t'en parle ils ont attendu qu'il soit
déjà un peu plus grande
ça fait deux ans qu'il m'en parle quand
j'avais 10 ans parce que à 10 ans j'ai
commencé à comprendre et ils m'en ont
parlé pour que j'avais pas tout avec yum
ces ballons quelqu'un m'appelle que j'y
aille pas avec lui que tu peut leur
poser toutes les questions que tu veux
oui tu te sens très libres de leur poser
la question que tu veux ah oui parce que
je sais que ryanair un dd qui me
répondra vous parlez beaucoup avec vos
enfants tous les deux oui ils pensaient
qu'ils vous disent tout je pense que si
on n'a pas confiance à ses parents alors
avec qui elle est ce que vous êtes le
plus important quand vous participez à
leur jeu ou quand vous leur faites faire
leurs devoirs
l'important pas tellement sur les
devoirs mais avec le jeu wii soit 127
milles ce qui manquerait beaucoup c'est
c'est surtout de à terme de manger tout
solde de vivre toute seule de dormir
tout seul c'est ça qui montra le plus
parce que bon on aggrave n'aurait pas
papa puis moment qui viendraient me
board il soir on mangerait pas ensemble
on mourir est pas tous ensemble c'est ça
qui
un très beau coup
[Musique]